あなたは
大丈夫だと思うので、これは
6人のように見えると思います
7人が今とても甘いです
始めましょ
う私は簡単にツイッターに投稿し
ます
ここでドーガンしたみんな
は、ライブストリームで今年を締めくくりたいと思ってい
ました。説明の情報からわかる
ように、blackmagic japanのように、
カメラ会社
は、私が自分たちの製品が本当に好きだと気づき
ました。 ええと、ポケットシネマカメラ
これ
は私がコメディービデオのためにいつも撮っているもの
です彼らは私が彼らの製品を使うのが楽しいことに気づいた
ので彼らは私にいくつかの
製品を送って
くれました だから
私はここにいくつかの新しいものを持っています私は
ストリーム全体でちょっと遊んでいます
が、ええと
、始めましょう
たくさんの人々が来
ているようです私は文字通り1時間前のようにあなたにサブスクライブしましたお
元気ですか 男お元気ですか
ロシアからこんにちわこんにちは愛を込め
て175どうやってやるの？
ええと
、彼らが送ったこのギアのクールなものの
1つは、彼らが送ったものの1つです。
ミニプロ
と実際に私はあなたにそれを見せ
ますええと、こんにちは、それは
リオ道元
ですので、私が
これを持っているこのカメラは現在ストリームに接続され
て
おり、私はこの本物に切り替えることができます さっそく
やらせてください。これはカメラ
4です。
皆さん、カメラが
私の顔に近すぎますが
、ここに行く
と、これが彼らが送信したものであることがわかります。これは
カメラスイッチャー
です。
戻ってこの
3つのボタンを押すと、フィードが
これに戻るので
、前後
に切り替えることができ
、コメディスタイルの設定のように
行くこともできます。 あそこは本当に速い
ので今私は私のコメディにい
ます私のコメディのセットアップは私の通常です
セットアップ
カラーグレーディング
を適切にセットアップする時間がなかった
ので、コンピューターに戻りますが、これで
、
このカメラの標準セットアップに戻る必要が
あります。 今のところ最高の色なので、
おそらくこれをストリームに使用すると思います
が、
これは本当にクールな
デバイスだと思います。また、実際
にプレイステーションをこれに接続しました
。これはおそらく少しだと思い
ます。 あまりにも
私はこれにカラーグレードを適用しています
これはストリームには少し暗すぎるかもしれません
私がobsで適用した文字列またはカラーグレードも
このプレイステーションストリームに適用されているので、
私は ただ
元に戻すだけです
が、本当にすべての種類に戻す
ことができるので、それを使ってあらゆる種類のクールなことを行うことができるので、クール
です。ストリームのライブカラー
グレーディングをどのように行うのですか。少し複雑です。
カメラソフトウェアのように黒い魔法を使うことができますt  o
別のカメラ内ソフトウェアで
は
、スイッチャーソフトウェア
を使用してストリームを評価するか、
現在
2つ
の組み合わせを実行しているので、これ
を使用するのは初めてです。 それで、私は
最初に物事を設定しているようなものです
。atemはカメラを個別にグレーディングできると思いますが
、p4kにlutを適用して、hdmi経由で出力することもでき
ます。p4kの意味はわかりませんが、ええと、
おそらく内部のlutを実行していると思います
私の本名が画面に表示されていますええ
と私の本名はどこに表示されていますか私は
今では遅すぎると
思いますが
ストリーミングする
ので
、視聴者からの質問に答えてみようと思います。
2020年を終わらせることができれば
、
楽しい
ライブストリームビデオがわから
ないので、実際には
両方のカメラを持っているのでエコーし
ますマイクがリグに接続されています さて
、立っている青いイエティマイクをオフに
します。オーディオが少し良くなることを願っています。
大丈夫、大分、カラナシのディスプレイが欲しいです。
私が住ん
でいて、そこにたくさんのかっこいいものを売っている大分な
ので、これは彼らが売ったものの1つです。
外の風がとても強い私の部屋の圧力のこと
それは私のエアコンのこのノック音のようになります
ああ私
はあなたの名前のシャナエ
が寄付をありがとうと言うことです
ええと
ソラトロールソート 本当に面白い
と思う前にあなたの作品をいくつか見たことがありますあなた
がやって
いることを
やっている日本人はあまりいないのでかっこいいです
いつかコラボレーションが好きになる
b ええ
、ストリームに参加してくれてありがとうii love
ii感謝しますええソーダは
今チャットで少し上がっています彼はもう
いなくなっているかもしれませんが
、カナダからのこんにちは私はあなたが素晴らしい新年を迎えることを願っています
2021年も安全を確保して
くださいええiiはわかりませんが、おそらくkovidがあった可能性があります。
他の人との交流のような前の推奨日
が終わるまでのように、
ええと、ええと、私は本当にひどい熱があり、
それは本当に荒れていて
、背中にこの本当にひどい痛みがあっ
たように、私は一日のように良くなったので私は
それが実際に
カバーされているかどうかはわかりませんが、
4Kのサブが好き
だったとき、私が大学にいたときはちょっと有名だったので、私は
4Kの
サブの道元とソーダのコラボレーション
です。
間違いなく私が続けようとした
ことをする必要があります ツイッターで一緒に行動します
が、複数のアカウントが
あったので、どれが正しいのかわからなかったので
、このライブストリームが終わったら、
私のように送ってください。連絡できます。
スウェーデンのおはようからおはようを
起こそうと思いますええと
、2021年の具体的な目標はあり
ますか？
私は私の水のボトルをあなたが知っている方法から外して移動させてください
私はyoutubeでパトレオンのことをする
か、
私が日本語の発音を教えるパトレオンで音声学のことをする
ので、これらは
私が日本語の発音を教えるために使う本のいくつかです
これらはすべて日本語の発音に関する本です
が、私はすでに日本語の発音について80のレッスンを行っ
ているので、これまでのところ、そのシリーズは
おそらく
日本語の発音を学ぶためのインターネット上で最高のリソースのようだと思い
ます。 本当にしっかりしていて、最近
、すべての
録音を、nhkアカデミーの
ようになったこの訓練された日本語スピーカーのような超高品質のネイティブ録音に置き換えている
ので
、そのシリーズを本当に誇りに思っていますが
、すでに80があります 高低アクセントや発音などの実用的な情報しかあり
ません
ので、シリーズに含まれる情報の量を
使い果たし始めています。ちなみに、
寄付に
感謝します。
実用性のレベルを上げてみ
て、かなり近い将来に新しいシリーズを作成する予定です。
これもパトレオン
専用シリーズになりますが
、その上で日本語の文法をカバーする予定
ですが、 私が
やろうとしているの
は、
2つの文法ポイントについて同時に
比較対照することです。
これは確かに私にとって真実であるためです。
第二に
、
日本語には非常によく似た文法のポイントがたくさん
あり、
ニュアンスが少し違うかもしれませんが、ほとんどの
人
は表面レベルのように学ぶだけだ
と思います。もう少し深く掘り下げることができれば
日本語で書くのにとても役立ち
ますし、できるだけ正確に自分を表現するのにも役立ち
ます。これが
良い例のように話します。たとえば、
3冊の本があると言えば、ホンガサンと言えます。
ニュアンス
の違いは何ですか
、それは私のシリーズで詳細に分解したいようなものですので、新しいシリーズでは
、ええと、誰かがゴミの味について道元を言ったのです
来てくれて
ありがとうええとアンディはすでにええと
日本語の発音を教えています発音では
なくええと文法申し訳ありませんそして彼は
パトレオンでも本当に良い仕事をしているので
みんな彼のパトレオンをチェックすることができ
ますええと、あなたがすでに日本の文法
について話しているビデオリソースに再び行くことに興味があるなら
、私のシリーズはポイントを紹介するようなもので
はなく、
おそらくあなたがすでに知っていて説明している2つのポイントを取るようなものになるでしょう
それらがどのように違うのかを詳しく説明してください。
そうですね、トラッシュテイスト
でドーガンをしました。
私は
コナーとギグックガーントと連絡を取り合っ
ています。ガーネットとはあまり話していないと思います
が、ジョーイのような人は本当に
うまく言っています。次回
東京にいるときは、私に知らせてください。
トラッシュテイストをお
届けしますので、いつでも大歓迎だと言われていますが、東京は今、um kovidで夢中になっているので、女の子が始まるまで本当に離れることはできません。
私には双子の娘がいて、双子がいるからといって学校に行く
のは好きです e
毎日がおかしいですが、彼らは
かなり早く学校を始めるでしょう
、それが起こったらおそらくあなたは来年の初めに知っているでしょう
、それで私はそれを楽しみにし
ています
ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、
私は九州に
います。私は
別府にいます。他のユーチューブは他にい
ないと思いますが、彼女はまだユーチューブをやっていますか？
どういうわけか、彼女は
ちょっとやめた
ほうがいいと思ったのかもしれませんが、また走っているのかもしれません。
間違ったことを考えているような気がしますが、
彼女はここにかなり近いクオコに
いるので、問題
は道元
道元かそこらです。 道元の正しい漢字は、
コピーしてそこに貼り付けるだけ
です。バターにバターを
付けてください。大分弁を話しますか。
私はそれを理解しますが、私はそれを話さない
でください。
私がpを教えているのでそれを知っています 高低アクセント
などのピッチアクトなど
は、ピッチアクションに関しては方言が違う
ので
、無意識のうちに話したいときは
、ピッチアクセントにあまり注意を払わないように、いつもわざと標準的な日本語を話そうとしています。
悪い習慣はまったくありません。いわば
、今参加しているばかりの人のために、もう一度このカメラに戻すことができ
ます。私は、カメラをブラックマジックする新しいギアを使用し
ています。 彼らは
たくさんのものを作っているのですが、
彼らは私に彼らのa10ミニプロを送ってくれ
ました。 私は
すでに2台のカメラを所有している
ので
、ボタンを押すだけで
別のカメラに切り替えるのが本当に簡単な
ものを送ってくれました。
だから私はtかどうかわからない 彼はいわば大きな
寄付
ですが、ええと、グプタ
は、私が滞在してもっと長く見たいと思っている寄付者に感謝します
が、新年の終わりまでにいくつかの文書を作成する必要があります。
それでも彼ら
に感謝しますそしてあなたの
文法シリーズで
私たちは最終的に
wa
との違いを明らかにしますそれは私がカバーすることを計画しているものの1つです
オーディオは
まだ機能
しています。
これを真剣にしたいと思う理由の1つについては、ここで少し話をしてみ
ます。これを真剣にしたいと思う理由の1つは
大学でこの決定的な瞬間を過ごしたので、
私は日本人の友人にその日テストがあることを伝えようとしていました
、
そしてええと、私は
私が言うべき
かどうか、私が言うべきかどうか、そして私がしなかったという事実を知り
ませんでした
あなたがそれで知っているようになっているはずだった私を知ってください
ポイント私は4年生の
日本の言語学専攻
でしたが、ニュアンスの小さな違いがわからなかったので、本当に
恥ずかしかった
ので
、その場で彼に聞いてみました。
基本的に、もしあなたがただ殺すなら、
それはあなたが他の日について話そうとしないならおそらく最も自然な言い方です
が、私はそれを言うことができるという点で多くの人が
おそらく
同じようなことを考えていると思い
ます こう言うことができますが
、
この2つの違いは何
ですか？新しいシリーズで取り上げたいのですが、このカメラからのチャットは実際には見えない
ので、
戻ってきます 私のデスクチャット
またはデスクカメラに
大丈夫ですそして私たちは戻ってき
ましたええ、照明は少しでしたええと
、このカメラはええとa2ミニプロと本当によく統合されているので、このカメラよりもそのカメラを評価するのは難しいです
しかし
、古いものはogbです。
それはそれがうまく統合されているかどうかわからないのですが、
これらの製品をもう少し研究する必要があり
ますが
、マイクは
大丈夫です。マイクはマイクである必要
があります。
マイク
はマイクである必要があります。 彼が日本語を話し
ているのを見た後、英語を話すこの男はとても奇妙に感じ
ますええ、それは
多くの人がそれらの違いを理解していると思うような
ものですが、
実際に
はそうではないので、私は思います
新しいシリーズは
、マイクの問題で申し訳ない多くの人にとって有益だと思います。
私が立っていたときに使用していたカメラは、それが原因
で採点が少し難しいという事実を説明しよ
うとしていました。 それは古い黒の
魔法の
カメラなので、ドゲンは
本当ですスターバックスストーリー100は
本当ですええと100パーセントではありません
がそれは真実の要素
を持っていますそして私は私たち全員がいわば危険地帯にいたと思います
g真夜中なので寝る
けど、ドーガンと言いたいだけです。あなたの
ビデオとユーモアのセンスが大好きです。
ありがとうございます。
おやすみなさい。おやすみなさい。
ドーガン、3年生の言語学専攻です。
私は最近、
日本語を真剣にパトレオンに登録することにし
ました。今日はすべての助けに感謝し
ます。このシリーズがお役に立てば幸いです。
今もパトレオンのシリーズは
発音に特化している
ので、高低アクセントや舌を置く場所も好きです
。 あなたの口の中で
そのようなものですが、
私は
比較的近い将来にパトレオンの文法
もカバーするでしょ
うあなたの将来の研究で頑張って
ください 新しいルート新しいルーク私
はそれを感謝します
ええ
、私はこれらのストリームを行うときはいつもちょっと驚いています
私は
すべてのコメントが同時に入ってくるように見るのはちょっと
圧倒されます beppuに住んでいた
英語のコメディを作っているyoutubeコメディアンを知っています
[音楽]
私は彼のyoutubeチャンネルを見る前に私がツイッターでこの男を見たことがあり
ます
彼が男だとは知らなかったけど、そうだね、
この男は知ってるよ。
たぶん彼とコラボするのも楽しいだろうと思う。
なぜジャージャービンクがみんなに嫌われているのか。
声を話します
ちょっとドーガン歓声と
ところで寄付をありがとうアルフレッド
ちょっと犬とブラジルからの歓声
私は日本人です私はただの
日本語愛好家ですそしてあなたのビデオは
それらすべての会話にユーモアをもたらすことによって私を大いに助けます
ブラジルに
行ったことはありません。行ったこと
はありません。たくさんの場所に行ったことはありませんが、ブラジル
に行ってみたいと思います。
特に、ブラジル
についてたくさんの良いことを聞いたことがあり
ます。あなたのチャンネルが大好きです。 そして、
あなたが私にアニよりもさらに日本語を学ぶように刺激する新しい新しいビデオを楽しみにしています
私は本当にもっと良いアニメを見る必要があります
それなら
タイタンへの攻撃の新しい季節は
本当に良い
です私は今のところそれを本当に楽しんでい
ますえ
えとええとアレックス
先生
[音楽]
外国人の寄付に感謝
します あなた
が日本に来たとき、別の先生が
あなたに、
ええと
、インフォーマルなカジュアルに少し似すぎ
ているかもしれないと言ったので、
あなたが先生で
もあり、あなたが好きでない限り、それは確かにあなたの先生と一緒に使いたいものではあり
ません 彼らと同じレベルで
私は私がああそうそう私の10歳の娘キャロラインを逃したかもしれないと思うのを見てみましょう
そして私はあなたのビデオを見るの
が大好きです クリスマスを祝わないなら
、メリークリスマスや幸せな休日を過ごせたことを願ってい
ます。将来の勉強で日本の
幸運を勉強し、素晴らしい新年を迎える
ことができれば
幸いです。 ええ大丈夫大丈夫hを確認してください
うまくいけば、あなたはまだ
ちょっとローガン
が2番目のちょっと犬を待つのを見ています、そして私は
数年間日本を勉強しています
、そしてそれは
いつもそれほど遠くないようですが、あなたのようなコンテンツ
は私が明日
緩み始めたときに
私をやる気にさせます 日本人の学習者にやる気を起こさせてくれてとてもうれしいです。
スーパーチャットからお金を持って日本に来てください
。貯金します。
[音楽]
ありがとうございます。
非常識なええ、私は
ええと、マンガを少し先読みしました、
そして私は
次のエピソードに本当に興奮しています私はすべて追いついていて、
私は実際に
私が今このシリーズを使っていることを使っています 長い間ここにいるので
、日本の日常生活に問題
がないので、日本語を学び続ける
ことを学びましょう。  wの
1つのような特定のフィールドのように
新シリーズの
オードは基本的に防御基地のような意味のyoloサイトで、
勉強を始めるまで、またはその
エピソードを見るまでその単語を知らなかったので
、フラッシュカードなどを使って新しい単語を作成する
ようなものでした 私
の姿勢に取り組まなければならないので、見栄えがよくありません。
元に戻して
ください。ええと
、百万で
はなく百万があるので、ええと
見てみましょう。 昔の仕事
の一環として日本のアメリカの基地のように回っていた
ので、それは
私がもっと慣れていたものだと言います。
日本語の発音
もとても良いので、
嫉妬し、学ぶ
気になります。ありがとうございます
。私の発音はかなり良いと思います。
私は実際よりも発音についてよく知っています。
再現する 私自身の発音では、
現実的には
8や8.5のような発音ですが
、確かに私よりも発音が良い外国人が他に
もいます。
たまたまこのテーマについてよく知っているので、
日本語を教えることができます。
発音
は私の発音が完璧
だからではなく、かなり
良いと思います
が、一般的な日本人の学習者よりも優れていると思います
が
、大学で集中的に発音を勉強した
ので、それについてよく知っ
ています。 私は
それをきちんと教えるようにしています
が、rの発音などの問題がまだ残っている
ので、
ダニエルは寄付をありがとう
mx50それがいくらかは
わかりませんが、
ありがとうございます。
みんなに寄付してくれてありがとう
本当に感謝して
います
漢字に関して
は、漢字を個別に学習しない
ことをお勧めします。私にとってうまくいったのは、
ankiやuhsrsの
アプリを使用するようなものです。
最後のsを覚えてい
ませんが、おそらく間隔反復システム
ですが、単一の漢字で
それを行うと、うまく機能しないことがわかりましたが、
漢字が含まれている個々の単語でそれを行うと、
本当に得られます
漢字を覚えるのに、
漢字を何十回も何十回も書くよりも、あるいは、語彙ではなく漢字に
特化した本のように使おうとするよりも、はるかにうまくいくことがわかりました
。語彙が道だと思います。
行くが、それ
は私自身の2つの感覚の一種ですええと本当に
あなたのコンテンツを楽しんでい
ます2021年にそれを維持してくださいドミニカ共和国からのたくさんの愛に感謝します
私は
彼が日本に住んでいるええとドミニカ共和国からの友人を持ってい
ます
tは話しました nしばらくの間、彼と一緒
に寄付してくれてありがとう、そして
親切な言葉を
ありがとうございます。また、よろしくお願いします。
[音楽]よろしくお願いします。 潜在的
にあなたのためのインスピレーション
のようなものです私はあなたが言おうとしていることだと思うので、私は
それを感謝し、
あなたの将来の研究で幸運を
祈ります
漢字の書き方
を学ぶのは大事なこと
ですが、少しズームアウトするとマクロレベルの話になると思います
ので、
漢字の書き方を学ぶ必要があると思います。
今の
ところ、
ほとんどの人が漢字を書くことを学ぶことはお勧めしません。
ほとんどの日本人
は
、一般的な外国人を知っているよりも平均的な筆順がはるかに優れていると思います
が、私は
今年一年中
漢字
で書いたのは、娘の就学前の申し込みだったのかもしれませんが、
ページくらいあり、娘がいるので、20
ページ分の申し込み
で、漢字を書いたことがありませんでした。
今年
、私がそれらを始めたとき、私は
ああ私の神のようでした
多分私は
漢字を少し上手に書く練習を知っているべきでした
か、あなたはそれがおそらくうまくいくことを知っている
ように感じます
かっこいい漢字が書けるのは本当にかっこいい
ですが、私にとって
は、日本語で書くよりも、日本語でジョークを言うのが好きな方が重要
な
ので、私にとっては優先事項ではありませんが、
あなた専用のyoutubeのチャンネルは、
書道などを知っているので
、それぞれに
大丈夫です。
あなたのシリーズは、ええと、馬鹿の
ような類似した名詞の違いをカバーしますか？
[音楽]
ごめんなさい1秒
すみませんもう少し読書に取り掛かる必要があり
ますええと、
最終的にはカバーすることを考えました。
違い
は個々の単語にもあるので
、
似たような語彙の違いもカバーしたいのですが、
文法はリーチが広いので、文法から始めると
、お金に見合うだけの価値を得ることができ
ます。
通常
、同じ文法ポイントを、そのための最良の
単語ではない可能性のある単語を使用するよりも、スピーチで頻繁に使用する
ためです。 特定の
例では
、
後で語彙を習得
しますが、間違っているものの1つを読んだので、もう一度言うことができますが
、それ
は、教える前に、研究についてもう少し宿題をする必要があることです。
そういうわけで、とにかくこれらの新しいレッスンを
作成するので、私はたくさんの研究をする
つもりです。ええと、私は
幻滅したエイカイワの先生の一人です。
ひどく行方不明の日本は
いいつか戻ってきたいのです
が、つながりの仕事を見つけるのに苦労していますえ
えと、残念ながら
私があなたに与えることができる唯一のアドバイス
はあなたが本当に強いスキルセットが好きでない限りあなたの寄付に感謝します
特定の分野で、
またはソーシャルメディアのようなものですでに大勢のフォロワーが
いるようなものは
、
おそらくアカイがあなたの唯一の道になるでしょうが
、私が言いたかったの
は、日本には幻滅した英語の先生もたくさんいるということです
私の経験ではそれらの多くは私の
前の自己
にも当てはまります確かに
彼らと私は最近これについてビデオを作ったの
ですがあなたは日本にうんざりしていないのでもっと幻滅し始めています しかし、あなたは
英語の先生であり
、日本に来たいと思っていた英語の先生になりたくなかったという事実にうんざりしている
ので、
あなたはそのようなスキルセットを開発する必要があります
日本に滞在して幸せを保つために、その英語の先生の軌跡を断ち切ることができます。
私が知っ
ているほとんどの人
は、
彼らがあなたに言ったので英語を教えるのをやめたために州に戻ったから
です。 私はしばらく日本で英語のことをし
ていましたが、99回は日本が恋しいと言わ
れました。それは、日本ではなかったという事実が、それが日本
であったことを示す本当に良い証拠です。 英語を教えているので
、日本に来る予定がある場合、
または
すでにここで英語の先生をして
いる場合
は、その軌道から抜け出す方法を考えてみるとよいでしょう。
あなたは
英語教育以外のことをして日本に滞在したい
と思っています。
なぜなら、日本は一般
的に住むのにとても良い場所だと思うから
です。 あなたがbamboozledwiを得た大きな脂肪
すべての外国人の甘い甘いバンド
例外はあり
ませんええと私はツイッターでそれについて何かを見ました
私は
すでにここに住んでいる外国人としてそれについてあまりよく知り
ませんそしてそれは私がいるので本当に私に影響を与えませ
ん すでにここに住んでいますが
、ツイッターで、
小学校時代にオキナワに住んでいた新しいバンドのよ
うなものがあると言われているのを見まし
た。特にオキナワは本当に面白
い場所です
。 日本ですが
、沖縄にはアメリカ文化の
ような要素がたくさんあり、日本人
も外国人との交流に慣れている
ので、私が住んでいる場所のように、
実際には日本人に対する外国人の比率が最も高いです
大学
のおかげで、ここにはたくさんの外国
人学生がいます。
ちなみに、私は約20分で行かなくてはなりませ
んでした。 別府に
住んでいるのか、沖縄や
東京にある程度住んでいるのか
というと、
東京はいつも夢中になっているので、東京ではちょっと
違い
ます。
すでに外国人との交流に慣れているので
、日本に来たいと
思っている人もいます。彼らは日本で唯一の
外国人に
なりたいので、その斬新で小さな町のようになりたいと思っています。
来て
、1
、2、3年
くらいここにいると、その目新しさがすり減ってしまうので
、自分
らしく快適に過ごせる場所に
なり
たいし、個人的なものもあると知っている
許容レベル何人かの人々
は、あなたが知っているように
、それは実際にはあまり私には起こらなかったと指摘したように気にしない
が、ええと、何
人かの人々はそれを無期限に扱うことが
できます t  o
できるだけ早くそれを乗り越え
て、
1対1の翼の天使
についての考えは素晴らしい曲です。ここで見ることができるよう
に、私は
大規模なファイナルファンタジーviiファンです。私は
ファイナルファンタジーについてのこの巨大な巨大な本のように
なりました。 まるでアートワークのようなもので、
そこに入ったものは
おそらくストリームで本の内部を表示することはできません。
それはいわばコッシャーのようなものではないと思いますが、
ファイナルファンタジーが大好きです。vii私がプレイしたシリーズが大好きです。
昨夜のps4で
約40分間、エクササイズバイクに乗っていました。
年前に大学を卒業したライオンスターで、日本
に住むことに興味のあるサプライチェーンで働いています。
大学に行く予定がない限り、大学経由で日本
に来る
ことをお勧めするのはちょっと躊躇し
ます。それは、あなたが望んでいないような大規模な投資だからです。  3つのように支払う
ドアに足を踏み入れるためだけに
数千ドル、または1万ドルや2万ドルのような大学の授業料の
場合は知っていますが、
すでに
行くつもりなら、おそらく州などのような潜在的により
高価な大学のように
そういうわけで、
それは確かにオプションです。
私の婚約者と私は日本に引っ越したかったのです
が、私たちは
貧しい黒と白の混合カップル
とその混合子供がツイートさ
れた方法を知っていました私は
知りません それについてはあまりにも多くのことですが、
ここでも非常に国際的です。大学
の親友の1
人はケニアの男です。
ケニア
だと思います。ウガンダから知っている別の男が
います。どちらも
ベプウムに住むのが大好きです。
私の知る限りでは
、そうですが、
個人の経験に基づいて
、カンジ学習のためのワニカニについてどう思いますか？
かなりの
pogersええと、それは本当に
あなたの目標が何であるかにかかってい
ます。もしあなたが本当に漢字に集中したいのなら、
特に
一つの経済が良いかもしれませんが、あなたが
あなたの語彙を増やすことにもっと興味があるなら、私は
むしろ マニカニよりも
、英語で英語になって、日本
での海外とのコラボレーションの計画をすぐに教えるために、個々の単語が含まれているカードデッキのようにしたほうがいい
でしょう。
来年初めに住んでいる日本や九州に行く
ので、
一緒に別のビデオを作る
と思います。少し前に彼と一緒にaqaのようにやりました。
私はクリスとかなり親密です。
クリスと彼のコンテンツが大好きです。
こんにちはドーガンのチャンネルはいつもおもしろい
です。 私は言っていない g
漢字を書くときは、漢字の
書き方を教えてくれる本を買って、具体的に
漢字を書きたいときに練習するのが好き
です。 いつでも大歓迎です。来年
もう少し時間が取れたら、
コナーとガーネットにも会いたいです。一緒にいた
ので
、両方とも連絡を取り合っています。 ちょっと
おしゃべりをしているねえドーガン百年以上前
の日本語の経験は何ですか
なつめ魂関ええとオーディオブックを
快適に聞くことができます
か？ 私
はジェットプログラムに参加していました。私はオートバイを持っていて、
日本語を練習
するために通勤で日本語を聞くことがありました。それは
通常の会話でしたが
、本の1つは私が1か月ほど聞いたものの1つです。
ゆめじゅやと呼ばれるこの短い日本語
ソルセキの本でした。特にこの本は
、
1か月か2か月ほど聞いて、自分がしなかっ
た単語のいくつかを調べて学んだ後、かなりよく理解
できました。 家に
帰った後や学校に行った後などはよくわかり
ますが
、一般的には100
歳の日本語
が苦手です。 日本語に
はたくさんのローンワードがあるので、ほとんど
圧倒さ
れます。外国人としての私にとって、
カタカナのローンワードを発音するのは、
通常の日本語の単語よりも難しい
ので、実際には難しいです。
英語で言わないようにする必要があるからです。 ええと
、いわばアクセントなので、アクセントが変わり
、発音が変わるので
、私にとって
は、日本語のネイティブの単語に固執するのが好きです。これ
は、日本語の有罪の単語のよう
な本当に良い例です。 罪悪感は
ザヤカンザヤックですが、
最近はガールフレンドと言う人も
い
ますが、r音が入っているので言いづらいですが、r音
に少し問題
があるので
、昔の日本人が好きですが あなたはそれについて何ができるか知ってい
ます私はすでに
そのトピックについて10本のビデオのように作りましたそしてそれ
は遅くならないようです
パンデミックが落ち着いた後のあなたの地域
ええと
、私は
この特定の地域にファン
が
いることを本当に知らなかったのかもしれません。 それは一種
のテーブルから外れていますが、ええ、
すべてが落ち着いたら
、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、ええと、あなたはええと、あなたはええと、
あなたはええと、日本は
あなたの子供を育てるのに良い場所だと思い
ますか？ 私のカリフォルニアの
ガールフレンドにそれがニックだと納得させる ええと、これを詳細に分析するの
は本当に難しいことです。
簡単な答えは、それは
あなたの価値観に依存し、公立学校で教えられている価値観に加えて、あなた自身の価値
観をどのように教え込むことができるかということです。
日本で
は一般的に創造性
が十分にカバーされてい
ないと思う
ので、あなた
の子供
に日本
を入れてください。 たくさん
の写真と
私は彼らに彼らの創造的な能力
を開発し続けるために開発を追求することを奨励し続けるつもりです
が、あなたがあなたの側にその余分な仕事を入れていなければ
、あなたの目標とあなたの価値観は
一致しません 公立学校で教えられているような日本の伝統的な
価値観で
は、健康管理は本当に良いと
言っている摩擦があるかもしれません。
人口の高齢化
と、すでにそのシステムに支払われている高齢者の社会保障が保証されているという理由だけで、彼は次の20年または30年
のように、
日本のように
たくさんの 外国人です
が、どうなるか見て
いきますので、いじめられているのですが、いじめられて
いません。
私がこのストリームを始めたときに答える準備を
している私は知らない
それについてはあなたの特定の状況についてです
が、私はおそらく
上司に行き
ます。ちなみに
、日本の外国の溶接工を知っ
ているので、いつかそこに引っ越したいのですが、
その会社を見つけるのは困難でした。 溶接工のための就労ビザ
は
ありませんが、私には予感があります。これは
単なる予感です。比較的近い将来、日本で
ビザや外国人のための新しいオープニングのようなものがあるかもしれないことを覚え
ておいてください。 アジアの人々
のプレッシャーを本当に感じ始め
、外国人が日本で働く機会を増やすかもしれないこと
に気づき始め
ます。たとえ彼らがあなたが知っている英語の教師のようでなくても、
溶接のような特定のスキルセットを
持っているので、うまくいけばその答え あなたの質問
とうまくいけば、それが
あなた
が年末のストリームをしているのを捕まえる
のに何と嬉しい驚きが起こるかこれをして
くれてありがとう
私の人生のこの特定の時点で私にとって私たちの市民権を放棄するの
が
好きなのは、私が主なもののように私たちの市民権を保持することの利点は何もないと思うからです
私は日本の米国市民であるため、毎年40時間ほど
米国の税金を日本の税金に加えて申請し、米国
政府にいくらかの金額を支払う必要があり
ます。40時間
は 私はお父さんなので、かなりの時間がかかり
ます。お父さんのときは
時間
がないので、今のところ、アメリカ市民権を保持
することで実際に利益が得られるのは好きではありません
が、
それ
は一種です。 保険証券のように、
日本で物事が本当に悪くなった場合、
不動産やヘルスケアなどがわからないので
、いつでも米国に戻ることができます。
そう、いわば保険証券です。
でも毎年
、アメリカ市民権を放棄することを真剣に考えているので
、今後4、5年で何が起こるかを見ていきます。
すでにストリーに出てきたすべての人のために
m
ブラックマジックをもう一度プラグインしますuhlloydlloyd
sapporo umからの笑いに感謝し
ますので、再び参加している人のために
私はこれを使用しています
私はこれを使用していますこれを使用し
ている
a2 mini  blackmagic japan
が私に貸してくれたプロで
、私は長い間使ってきた他の
この他の製品もたくさん持って
いる
ので、私は現在このカメラのようにしてい
ます これで撮影するのは、
彼らが私に貸してくれた黒い魔法のカメラである黒い魔法のポケットシネマカメラですが
、彼らが送ってくれたこのスイッチャーを使え
ば、そのボタンを押すと
本当に簡単に切り替えることができます
さまざま
なカメラを知っているかどうかを切り替えてください。オーディオのようにいくつかのクールなトリックを行うことができます。また、よりプロフェッショナル
に見えるようにすることもでき
ます。これら
を貸してくれたblackmagicのおかげで
、私
はすでに知っているようにあなたの製品が大好きです。
あなたが私にええとさせてくれる限り、これらを使うことを計画している
ので
、あなたがあなたのコメディスキットをするとき、あなたの後ろにある本の名前は何ですか？
その本がとても好きで、
それが本当に哲学的であることを私は知って
います、そしてそれが誰にとっても正しい哲学であるとは思わないので、それが誰にとっても正しい哲学であると言っているわけではありませんが、私は
その本がとても好きで、
他の 本は
あなたがタッキーなので、
それは私が本当に好きな別の本である金原下見の本です。
私
が最初
に創造的な執筆
を始めた主な
理由の1つであり、日本語での創造的な執筆もその
本の
おかげです。
ブロなぜあなたの声
は英語でとても違うのですか
私はできません残念ながらもうバックフリップをすることはできません
が多分いつか
私がすべての関節を完全に修復した
ときええと
私はその質問に答えましたか
あなたのチャンネルを愛することについての質問でした、そして
あなたが私にインスピレーションを与える新しいビデオを楽しみにしてい
ます ジョークビデオに使用するレンズ
レンダリングとカラー
操作は非常に特徴的であるため
、
メタボーンスピードブースターに接続
され、元のブラックマジックポケット
シネマカメラに組み込まれるシグマアート30ミリメートル1.4
なので
、初心者にどの本をお勧めしますか
日本の
元気を学ぶのは本当に良い本です
元気は実際にpogchampと言います
pogchampあなたはあなたの家であなたの両親が恋しいですかええと
私は私の家で私の両親が恋しいです
ええと、
私たちがどこで会えないか知っ
ていますが、彼ら
はこの時点で60代後半であるため、この期間中はとにかく会うことができませんでした。
zza shopええと、あきさんに
聞いてみてください。彼女
は日本のドミノのようなええと、たくさんのビデオを
作ってくれました。それらのビデオはいつも
本当にいいです。あと2分で、
だましをやめ
ました。
ええと、2015年12月でした
。また、私の体は
だまされたためにバラバラになっていたので、ちょっと止めなければなり
ません
でした。
子供
たちを交代で見ているので、ちょっと待ってください。でも、それが
そのノイズです。
タイトルを説明して
ください
。 漢字
も説明できないので
残念ながら
私はあなたのコンテンツマンが大好きですええとあなたは私が4年間
日本語を学び続ける意欲を保ち
、私の日本の子供たちにあなたのビデオを推薦し
ます 誰かがそのよと言うなら毎回私にたくさん
彼ら
は私のビデオを見てインスピレーションを得ていることを知っているので、
ありがとうございます。あなた
が州に来るとき、良い
新年を迎えます。 私が担当しているのはディスコードサーバーで
はあり
ません他の人がやっているのかわからないことがあるかもしれません
私は本当にそれ
に夢中になったので、ええと、基本的に時間切れだと
思うので、
ここで
もう一度終了し
ます。この本当にクールなカメラ機器を貸してくれた
blackmagicに感謝します。
これらすべての異なるカメラを切り替えることができるタイマー
私の通常のカメラ私のプレイステーション
[音楽]
このカメラ私のカメラはここにあります
blackmagicは、ビデオ制作に取り掛かろうとしている人々のために、本当にクールなリソースをたくさん作ります。
youtubeのように あなたは
YouTubeに興味があるか、YouTubeチャンネルを始めようとし
ているので、blackmagicをチェックしてください。私は
いつも彼らのものを使っていて、大好きです
が、ええと、ここでストリームを終了する必要があります
。
これを楽しんだ私
は、来年の2021年が今年よりも少し
良く
なることを願っていますが、良いスタートを切ることができれば幸い
ですが、来てくれたみんなに感謝し
ます。
新年と私はあなた
たちみんなとすぐにまた話します